PLAYERS TO DISCUSS RACE.
BUT FIRST, WHAT IS NEXT RUSSIAN
MARK THAT IS THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
AND WHAT WAS PERHAPS THE MOST
CONSEQUENTIAL TWEETS ON
SELECTION DAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP
GAVE THE GO-AHEAD FOR THE
TRANSITION.
YOU SEE IT THERE.
AND DOESN’T AS UNPLEASANT THESE
WEEKS HAVE BEEN, THIS IS WHERE
THINGS STAND TONIGHT.
NOW, LEGAL CHALLENGES CONTINUE
IN A NUMBER OF STATES.
SERIOUS QUESTIONS ABOUT VOTE
COUNTING, POLE ACCESS, BUT
UNLESS THE LEGAL SITUATION
CHANGES IN A DRAMATIC AND
UNLIKELY MANNER, JOE BIDEN WILL
BE INAUGURATED ON JANUARY 20TH.
NOW, TO SAY THIS DOES NOT MEAN I
DON’T THINK THAT THE SELECTION
WAS RIFE WITH PROBLEMS AND
POTENTIAL FRAUD.
TO SAY THIS DOES NOT CONSTITUTE
BEING A SELLOUT TO THE
CONSERVATIVE POPULIST MOVEMENT
I’VE BEEN FIGHTING FOR HER FOR
25 YEARS.
IT DOES NOT MEAN THAT I AGREE IT
ALL TO PURSUE LEGAL CHALLENGES
TO THIS OUTCOME.
TO SAY THIS CONSTITUTES LIVING
IN REALITY.
AND IF I OFFER YOU A FALSE
REALITY, IF I TOLD YOU THERE WAS
AN EXCELLENT PHENOMENAL CHANCE
OF THE SUPREME COURT STEPPING IN
AND DELIVERING A VICTORY TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP, I WOULD BE
LYING TO YOU.
NOW YOU HAVE KNOWN ME FOR A LONG
TIME NOW.
YOU KNOW ME LONG ENOUGH TO KNOW
THAT I WILL NOT LIE TO YOU OR
SIMPLY TELL YOU WHAT YOU WANT TO
HEAR.
BUT WHAT I WILL TELL YOU TONIGHT
IS THAT EVEN ADMITS TO AN
ELECTION A LOSS, THERE IS AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT FOR US TO BE
HOPEFUL ABOUT.
EVEN OPTIMISTIC.
AND HOW ARE HANDLED GOING
FORWARD IS GOING TO HAVE A HUGE
IMPACT ON THE REPUBLICANS
ABILITY TO STOP AT BIDEN’S MOST
EGREGIOUS MOVES.
AND THUS, THESE NEXT MOVES ARE
CRITICAL TO THE FUTURE OF THE
COUNTRY.
AND THANKS TO PRESIDENT TRUMP,
WE HAVE SEEN THE AMAZING RESULTS
THAT ARE POSSIBLE WITH HIS
AMERICA FIRST AGENDA.
MIDDLE INCOME, BLUE-COLLAR
WORKERS SAW UNPRECEDENTED WAGE
GAINS.
THE MIDDLE EAST, HISTORIC PEACE
DEALS NOBODY THOUGHT WAS
POSSIBLE.
OF COURSE, WE SAW CHINA FINALLY
PUT BACK ON ITS HEELS ON TRADE
AND BECAUSE OF THE HARD WORK AND
TALENTED PEOPLE TRUMP BROUGHT
INTO HIS ADMINISTRATION DURING
THE PANDEMIC, HE KEPT OUR
ECONOMY GOING AFTER YOUR BRIEF
SHUTDOWN AND WITH OPERATION WARP
SPEED HE MARSHALED THE RESOURCES
TO END THIS SCOURGE.
SO WHAT HE DID FROM THE TIME HE
WAS INAUGURATED THROUGH NOW --
IT WORKED.
PERIOD.
AND NEARLY 74 MILLION AMERICANS,
THE LARGEST NUMBER TO EVER TURN
OUT FOR A REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT,
THEY VOTED FOR HIM.
A MORE DIVERSE COALITION THEN
MOST OF US EVER THOUGHT WOULD
HAPPEN.
LIKE WHO PREDICTED REPUBLICANS
WOULD GAIN SO MANY SEATS IN THE
HOUSE?
ALL THE EXPERTS SAID IT WAS
IMPOSSIBLE.
THEY FLIPPED 11 SO FAR AND ARE
ON TRACK TO UNSEAT EVEN MORE
DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS ALL BECAUSE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
DITTO FOR THE REPUBLICAN GAINS
AND STATEHOUSES ACROSS AMERICA.
NOW TODAY WE SEE THAT BIDEN --
WHAT IS HE DOING?
WELL, HE’S PICKING MOSTLY BLAND
RETREADS TO HIS CABINET.
JOHN KERRY WILL BE MR. CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THE GLOBALIST AND LONGTIME BIDEN
FLUNKY, AND JANET YELLEN, FORMER
HEAD CHAIR UNDER OBAMA HEADS TO
TREASURY.
AND THE U.N. WILL GET -- WE WILL
GET TWO MORE OF THEM LATER ON.
NOW BIDEN’S ENTIRE
ADMINISTRATION IS BASICALLY
GOING TO LOOK LIKE A RERUN OF
THE SERIES CANCELED FOUR YEARS
AGO, EXCEPT THIS TIME WITHOUT
ITS POPULAR LEADING MAN, OBAMA.
NOW WE KNOW WHAT THEY ARE GOING
TO DO.
WHAT OBAMA DID, BUT IT’S GOING
TO BE WORSE.
CUTTING OIL AND GAS JOBS, OPEN
BORDERS WITH NO DEPORTATIONS,
MASSIVE CONCESSIONS TO EUROPE ON
TRADES, IT’S GOING TO KILL OFF
SO MANY OF OUR MANUFACTURING AND
JOBS.
A CLIMATE CHANGE DEAL, AND
ELIMINATION OF TARIFFS THAT WILL
ALLOW CHINA TO RUN THE TABLE ON
EVERYONE.
AND MUCH, MUCH MORE.
BUT SOME OF THIS NONSENSE CAN BE
STOPPED.
IF REPUBLICANS HOLD THE SENATE.
NOW THAT MEANS THE POLITICAL
CAPITAL THAT IS SPENT BETWEEN
NOW AND JANUARY 5TH SHOULD BE
SPENT CONVINCING THE PEOPLE OF
GEORGIA TO HOLD THE LINE.
NOW IN A STUNNING NEW SURVEY
THREE WEEKS BEFORE THE ELECTION,
WE ARTY HAVE 50% -- 56% OF
AMERICANS WHO WANT REPUBLICANS
TO KEEP THE SENATE.
IT’S AMAZING.
NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP CAN HELP
DELIVER THOSE VICTORIES.
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
I EXPECT AND I HOPE THAT IN THE
PRESIDENT WILL ANNOUNCE A SERIES
OF RALLIES ACROSS GEORGIA WHERE
HE CELEBRATES HIS HUGE NUMBER OF
SUCCESSES OF THE PAST FOUR YEARS
AND EXPLAINS WHY SENDING TO FAR
LEFT RADICALS TO THE SENATE IS
ONLY GOING TO EMBOLDEN THE WORST
INSTINCTS OF THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
NOW WINNING THOSE TWO STATES
WILL BE A GREAT WAY TO EMBOLDEN
THE REPUBLICAN RESISTANCE ACROSS
AMERICA AND TO SEND A VERY CLEAR
MESSAGE THAT BIDEN AND HIS TEAM
HAVE ZERO MANDATE TO PULL OUR
COUNTRY TO THE HARD LEFT.
THIS IS A TIME FOR THE PRESIDENT
TO REMIND ALL AMERICANS THAT WE
WILL SAVE THIS COUNTRY.
EVEN WITH THE CURRENT SETBACK.
GREAT PATRIOTS GREAT PATRIOTS
COAST TO COAST GIVEN UP.
THEY DO NOT WANT US TO BE MERE
PUPPETS OF EUROPE AND THE CCP.
AND UNLIKE THOSE WHO GATHER AND
PINE ABOUT THE END OF NATIONAL
BORDERS, UNLIKE THOSE WHO TEAR
DOWN OUR HISTORY AND SPIT ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT, WE BELIEVE IN
THE GOODNESS OF OUR PEOPLE.
AND THE RIGHTEOUSNESS OF OUR
FOUNDERS AND OUR CONSTITUTION.
WE BELIEVE OUR INDEPENDENCE
CANNOT BE SUBLIMATED TO A GLOBAL
ORDER DETERMINED BY
UNACCOUNTABLE BUREAUCRATS IN
BRUSSELS OR IN PARIS.
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO GET UP
AND EARN A LIVING EVERY DAY --
THEY NEED TO KNOW THAT THEY
STILL HAVE CHAMPIONS WHO BELIEVE
THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD WORK FOR
THEM, NOT AGAINST THEM.
AND THAT MEANS WE NEED
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO CONTINUE
ADVOCATING FOR AMERICAN
EXCEPTIONALISM AND CONTINUE
REACHING OUT TO COMMUNITIES WHO
HAVE BEEN LIED TO OR POORLY
SERVED FOR GENERATIONS.
AND I THINK THAT WHEN WE GET
INTO 2021-2022, WE WILL HAVE
SEEN TEAM BIDEN STUMBLE FROM ONE
CRISIS TO ANOTHER.
AND VOTERS -- OH, YEAH, --
VOTERS WILL START WONDERING WHEN
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A PRESIDENT
WHO ONCE AGAIN LOOKS OUT FOR OUR
INTEREST FOR LESS.
THINKING ABOUT THIS TODAY, THE
DEEP STATE SHIFT, PELOSI, BIG
ATTACK, THE MEDIA, WALL STREET,
THEY SHOVELED MONEY AT BIDEN.
PRO ATHLETES WHO MAKE MILLIONS
IN CHINA.
THEY ALL DID EVERYTHING THEY
COULD TO DESTROY TRUMP.
AND A PANDEMIC THAT ORIGINATED
IN CHINA.
AND YET WITH ALL OF THAT ON
JANUARY 21ST 2020, HE WILL STILL
BE THE MOST IMPORTANT PERSON IN
AMERICAN POLITICS IF HE WANTS TO
BE.
AFTER ALL, WE ALL KNOW BIDEN IS
NOT GOING TO BE THE ONE CALLING
HIS OWN SHOTS.
PEOPLE I DON’T THINK REALIZE
WHAT IT’S GOING TO BE LIKE WHEN
WE HAVE MORE THAN 70 MILLION
AMERICANS MAD AT THE WAY THE
GOVERNMENT IS RUN UNDER TEAM
BIDEN.
IT’S TRUE, THE DEMOCRATS WERE
MAD FOR FOUR YEARS, BUT AT LEAST
FOR MOST OF THAT THEY HAD
INCREDIBLE PEACE AND PROSPERITY
TO ENJOY.
ADDRESSING THE IRREGULARITIES
AND INSTANCES OF POSSIBLE FRAUD
IN THE SELECTION, IT PROBABLY
WON’T BE POSSIBLE BEFORE TRUMP
LEAVES OFFICE.
BUT WHAT HE COULD DO, AND THIS
IS JUST AS IMPORTANT AS GEORGIA,
AS A POINT A COMMISSION ON
ELECTION REFORM.
THIS GROUP MUST INVESTIGATE
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED IN STATES
LIKE PENNSYLVANIA, MICHIGAN,
ET CETERA, AND OFFER SERIES
RECOMMENDATIONS TO SEE THAT THIS
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
THERE IS ZERO REASON WHY EVERY
STATE IN AMERICA CAN’T BE LIKE
FLORIDA OR TEXAS AND CALL THIS
THING ON ELECTION NIGHT.
THIS CANNOT TO TURN DOES NOT TUR
TO BE A WAY TO BURY REPUBLICANS.
BELIEVE ME, I THINK THE
DEMOCRATS ARE HOPING OR BETTING
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP RAILS ON
ABOUT HOW THE LEE ELECTION WAS
RIGGED AND SO FORTH.
I DON’T THINK THERE’S A NEED FOR
HIM TO KEEP RELITIGATING THAT IN
THE COURT OF PUBLIC OPINION
BECAUSE A HUGE PERCENTAGE OF
AMERICANS ARTY BELIEVE THAT.
TRUMP REMAINS THE MOST
COMPELLING VOICE IN AMERICAN
POLITICS.
AND THIS THANKSGIVING, WE SHOULD
ALL BE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR
HIS SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY AND
HIS SACRIFICES FOR THIS COUNTRY.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS, NO
ONE ELSE, AT LEAST RIGHT NOW,
CAN BRING THE ENERGY, DRAW THE
CROWDS, AND ATTRACTS NEW VOTERS
LIKE LATINOS AND
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AS HE DID.
AND I PERSONALLY CANNOT WAIT TO
SEE WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES
NEXT.